[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en Bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy hablamos de las importantes
relaciones entre la Unión Europea y
América Latina en un año que se
considera clave entre ambas regiones con
una Cumbre entre los 27 y los países de
la celac en apenas un mes y medio y con
la vista puesta Ahora más que nunca en
fortalecer estas relaciones lo
analizamos con los eurodiputados Javi
López del grupo socialdemócrata y
presidente de la asamblea eurolad
bienvenido Javi Muchas gracias por
invitarme Igualmente por estar aquí
muchas gracias y con José Manuel García
margarillo también vicepresidente de la
misma asamblea y ex ministro de asuntos
exteriores de España bienvenido José
Manuel Muchas gracias a los dos por
estar aquí 2023 como comentábamos puede
convertirse en un año clave de las
relaciones entre América Latina y la
Unión Europea y una Cumbre muy esperada
con los países de la celac también
importantes acuerdos comerciales en
proceso de cerrarse de ratificarse
visto ahora la vista atrás la Unión
Europea descuidado sus relaciones con
América Latina Javi Durante los últimos
10 años la Unión Europea ha estado muy
atenta con otras prioridades
Especialmente con los incendios que
teníamos en nuestra vecindad que
continúan de alguna forma u otra en el
este especialmente pero también en
Oriente medio y resolviendo crees crisis
internas no solo ha sido una cuestión de
la Unión Europea también hay que
recordar que latinoamérica ha tenido
varias crisis internas que han
dificultado una relación birregional
constante y no solo eso sino también
divisiones dentro del seno de los
espacios regionales latinoamericanos
ahora se da el contexto para poder
empujar en las relaciones entre ambos la
guerra empuja a la Unión Europea a una
visión más estratégica del mundo y un
comportamiento más estratégico de la
acción exterior nuestras relaciones con
América Latina son fundamentales
para reconstruir el multilateralismo muy
dañado y puesto en jaque después de la
invasión de Ucrania para resolver las
grandes crisis energéticas seguridad
alimentaria transición ecológica que hoy
la comunidad internacional tiene que
encauzar Y tenemos una Cumbre después de
ocho años para hacer todo eso y tres
acuerdos de asociación muy relevantes
que pueden fortalecer la relación con la
región no modernizarlos de chile y
México y el acuerdo con mercosur
precisamente
estábamos hablando de esta Cumbre la
celac que se va a celebrar A mediados de
Julio hace 8 años que no se celebra
ninguna puede convertirse en un
trampolín en un cambio en estas
relaciones entre la Unión Europea y
América Latina José Manuel vamos a ver
yo creo que ese cambio es absolutamente
imprescindible en estos momentos estamos
viviendo en un mundo Cada vez más
Bipolar en que hay una división entre lo
que podíamos Llamar las democracias
liberales occidentales y los países que
quieren crear un orden internacional
diferente y América Latina es el mejor
candidato para formar parte fuera de lo
que es Europa de ese y Estados Unidos de
ese mundo de democracias liberales hay
un francés precisamente que sea philippe
que tiene un libro que es que se le
excitó en que dice Cuáles son los
valores que definen a occidente la
democracia y la libertad griega el
derecho romano la solidaridad que viene
de la ci judío cristiana y los derechos
humanos y la libertad que vienen de la
de la Ilustración y en el mundo quien
más se parece a nosotros en la
aceptación de esos valores es América
Latina ahora con ocasión de Rusia hemos
visto que hay un Gran Sur en que la gran
mayoría ha condenado la invasión como no
podía ser de otra manera pero se han
negado a seguir los procedimientos
sancionadores con Rusia juegan juegan a
dos aguas Brasil es el gran ejemplo pero
tienes también América Latina gente que
ni siquiera condenó la invasión por
tanto si queremos Buscar occidente fue
países que compartan nuestros valores en
un momento en que la demografía va en
contra nuestra el candidato es América
Latina partiendo de ahí tenemos que
sacar las consecuencias y establecer
relaciones más estrechas que pasen de
Las Musas al teatro como decía Lope de
Vega estos acuerdos están bien pero que
es más de lo mismo decir yo creo que hay
que tener una visión completa de Cuál es
la relación entre América Latina y la
Unión Europea más la relación con la
relación transatlántica José Manuel
hacía mención al papel de Brasil estás
de acuerdo que está un poco jugando a
dos aguas Es verdad que ha hecho
declaraciones Lola da Silva un poco
contradictorias podríamos decir en
primer lugar cualquier iniciativa que
tenga como objetivo la paz comparte los
objetivos europeos pero cualquier
iniciativa que tenga como objetivo a la
paz tiene que tener en cuenta una
premisa básica en el caso del conflicto
en la invasión de Ucrania que estamos
ante una agresión de una potencia
nuclear a un país vecino y que aquí hay
un agresor y un agredido y cualquier
solución tiene que pasar por el respeto
al derecho internacional público que
quiere decir respeto a la soberanía de
los países y su integridad territorial
no sobre la política de sanciones la
verdad que tiene un cáliz diferente solo
Estados Unidos Europa está articulando
una política de sanciones global el
resto de países no de entidades no lo
hacen lo relevante es que en Naciones
Unidas tanto Brasil como América Latina
eso son las partes del sur global
comparados con áfrica o Asia que más
están apoyando las resoluciones de
condena explícita Clara también Brasil
como hemos dicho de la invasión antes
hacía mención
a José Manuel sobre el papel que tiene
nuestras relaciones Yo creo que es muy
importante en el mundo convulso en el
que vivimos de reordenación del orden
internacional como una vieja amistad
como la nuestra somos viejos amigos con
unas grandes relaciones culturales
humanas económicas el primer inversor
europeo en el continente y no solo eso
sino muchos valores compartidos Cómo
podemos convertir una vieja amistad en
una alianza de carácter estratégico para
entre otras cosas evitar la bipolaridad
del mundo que puede ser un escenario en
el que nos veamos encaminados una
bipolaridad muy peligrosa nosotros que
defendemos los europeos un mundo Regido
por las normas un mundo Regido por los
órganos internacionales y el derecho
internacional y tenemos unos aliados en
este sentido en América Latina también
en Brasil precisamente sobre la
bipolaridad a la que hacía referencia
Javi esto afecta también por ejemplo
esta se habla de una inminente guerra
fría entre Estados Unidos y China hay
que ver Hay ciertos matices al respecto
chile china dicho que cada vez está más
presente en la región tiene acordes
comerciales con Perú Costa Rica chile
Ecuador está negociando con Uruguay de
alguna forma la Unión Europea puede
compensar el terreno que ha ido ganando
china con estos años vamos a ver sobre
el orden sobre el orden internacional
desde hace días mucho tiempo china
ha denunciado el orden liberal
internacional que nos dimos después 45
como un conjunto de reglas hechas por
los países de élite para seguir
afirmando su dominio en el mundo y
ofrece un modelo alternativo que es el
modelo del leninismo como partido único
y el capitalismo casi si casi sin reglas
y ese es un modelo muy atractivo para
aquellos países a los que les molesta
que se condicionen la ayuda o la
cooperación comercial al respecto de
ciertos valores
en 2019 se concluyó un acuerdo entre la
Unión Europea y el bloque de mercosur
antes has hecho referencia a Javi ahora
se están esperando una serie de
propuestas por para proteger contra la
deforestación también se están esperando
contra propuestas también del bloque de
mercosur pero es un pacto que nació
desde el principio con problemas con
reservas de algunos países ya hay
posibilidades de que prospere realmente
este acuerdo hay potencial para que
prospere pero no niego las dificultades
objetivas por lo que pasa hoy en por lo
que pasa hoy en el mercosur obviamente
los países del mercosur y especialmente
Brasil que lidera las negociaciones y
las conversaciones con la Unión Europea
viene a decir si se reabre lo que ya
estaba negociado en el 2019 con nuevos
condicionantes que tienen que ver como
el medio ambiente se tiene que poder
hablar de otras cosas algo que me parece
razonable Hay que decir que ellos están
muy interesados especialmente en que sus
relaciones comerciales apuesten por la
industrialización y el valor añadido
dentro de sus economías y no hacer
depender sus economías como pasado en el
pasado y ha tenido varios problemas de
derivado de eso en las commodities y la
exportación de materias primas sí que es
una necesidad que hay que atender y al
mismo tiempo aquí dentro de la Unión
Europea tenemos varios países
especialmente Francia que bajo el
pretexto del medio ambiente lo que está
escondiendo es una pulsión
proteccionista y la voluntad de que la
Unión Europea no lleve a cabo acuerdos
de carácter comercial
mi punto de vista es que esta cuerda que
sería el mayor acuerdo firmado entre la
Unión Europea y un tercer actor en su
historia tiene un enorme potencial
porque es un carácter un acuerdo de
carácter estratégico para nosotros que
nos puede afianzar la relación con
cuatro grandes países dos grandes
actores Argentina y Brasil miembros del
g20 y que no solo estamos ante una
operación de carácter comercial sino una
operación de carácter estratégico No eso
es lo que yo creo que tenemos entre
manos y es una enorme oportunidad dentro
de la política española que existe
consenso en empujar en este sentido Y
estoy convencido de que vamos a
continuar haciéndolo Durante los
siguientes meses me queda Una última
pregunta José Manuel que me gustaría
hacer hablábamos de este cambio de
paradigma de paradigma que ha supuesto
la guerra en Ucrania también en las
relaciones con América Latina ha habido
puede haber cambios también con las
relaciones con Venezuela a raíz de esta
guerra vemos
que Estados Unidos ha autorizado a
operar a Chevron en Venezuela para
extraer petróleo podrías haber también
una aproximación a la unión de la Unión
Europea hacia Venezuela que haya también
un cambio en este sentido yo creo que en
las relaciones con todos estos países
Especialmente con Venezuela la actuación
de la Unión Europea tiene que estar muy
coordinada muy sincronizada con la
acción de los Estados Unidos no tendría
sentido que tuviésemos políticas
diferentes pero el problema no solo es
Venezuela el problema y si hablamos de
mercosur Es que la inestabilidad en los
países que forman mercosur allí es tal
que es muy dudoso que puedan centrar su
atención en este acuerdo en Brasil el
presidente Lula se encuentra con una
asamblea que está controlada todavía por
el bolsonalismo en Chile el presidente
boric se ha encontrado con que las
elecciones a la asamblea Constituyente
han sido ganadas por la derecha y por la
derecha más extrema podcast en Argentina
está en una situación permanente de
inestabilidad con un fin de ciclo de lo
que es el kirchnerismo y el único país
que siempre ha apostado por mercosur de
verdad y que le ha preocupado es Uruguay
es posible que avancemos mucho con
mercosur yo lo dudo Es verdad que hay
reticencias en algunos países en la
Unión Europea javiercita o Francia pero
comparadas con las reticencias y las
dificultades que hay Al otro lado del
Atlántico vamos eso es pecata minuta es
ese es el problema y la realidad en la
que nos encontramos América Latina está
en una situación muy muy complicada
Gracias José Manuel Javi Lamentablemente
nos hemos quedado sin tiempo muchas
gracias a ustedes les esperamos en el
próximo programa de Europa hoy Gracias
por ver France 24 en español
[Música]